all right we're live welcome to the live
stream hey everybody a lot to talk about
today wasn't going to stream today
actually but so much stuff is going on
that I am going to do a stream will talk
about the State of the Union dust-up
that's going on I believe Nancy Pelosi
will ultimately prevail if she wants to
we will talk about that in a little bit
of detail we are going to talk about
Michael Cohen postponing basically
indefinitely I mean basically what he's
saying is if it's up to him he's
cancelling his testimony to the House
Oversight Committee citing threats from
Rudy Giuliani and Donald Trump we will
talk about that we could maybe talk
about Venezuela if people want me to
although I will be dealing with that in
more detail on tomorrow's show something
about this cable is weird and we can
also talk about the story claiming Rudy
Giuliani's drinking may actually be the
explanation for his bizarre behavior
during television interviews all of
those possible stories on the table this
is a live stream if you've not watched
the live streams before the big
difference with the other stuff we put
up on YouTube is that they're live you
can use the super chat function that's
the dollar sign at the bottom of the
chat window to send comments to ask
questions I will put them up on the
screen they will appear here which is
cool you can start sending those now and
I will get to them and importantly sign
up for membership using the coupon codes
in the description to get a live thank
you and importantly I will also open up
the phone lines if we get 10 new members
during the live stream it costs money to
take phone calls and that is why we
usually have some kind of membership
Channel please don't troll the live chat
it's annoying I only pay some attention
to it there are moderators who pay more
attention to it than I do and you can
also use the join button below this
video to become a YouTube channel member
so let's get right into it because there
is so much going on a first story a
Donald Trump's personal lawyer former
personal lawyer Michael Cohen says he's
not going to testify before the House
Oversight Committee anymore he's
scheduled to go to prison on March 6th I
believe it is does this article mention
it made
further down he was scheduled to testify
before the House Oversight Committee on
February 7th we were looking forward to
this for a number of different reasons
not so much because we were expecting
bombshells about privileged information
or things that are as yet unknown
regarding the Trump Russia probe because
I'm I would guess that Cohen's attorneys
would tell him it's not a good idea to
get involved in that because that could
be seen as trying to influence testimony
or affecting an ongoing investigation
but if anyone has the goods on Trump
it's Michael Cohen so I wanted to see
him testify Donald Trump did not want to
see him testify and now Cohen is saying
he will postpone indefinitely that
testimony because of threats from Donald
Trump and Rudy Giuliani to him and his
family now this there are two possible
interpretations to this one is all this
is referencing is Donald Trump saying
that Cowen's Trump and Giuliani talking
about Cohen's father-in-law as a
criminal and saying that he should be
investigated if that's what Cohen means
you know are those threats against Cohen
and his family in in in the literal
sense I don't know but if what if what
if is being pointed to here by Michael
Cohen is something we've not yet learned
about threats that have not yet yet gone
public then that is a really really big
deal and I hope that we will at some
point figure out exactly what those
threats are up at the beginning of the
article it does also mention what is
expected to happen next with regard to
Michael Cohen's testimony because he was
voluntarily going in there is still the
possibility of a subpoena and as the CNN
article states Democrats are now
considering whether to subpoena Cohen to
compel his testimony before he reports
to prison next month at least one senior
Democrat on the House Oversight
Committee says he expects chairman
Elijah Cummings of Maryland to issue
that subpoena I hope that he does and
the United States of America is more
than equipped
to protect Michael Cohen and his family
from any kind of physical danger now if
indeed there is anything to the
allegations that Donald Trump is
throwing around about Michael Cohen's
father-in-law that's a different story
altogether but remember using the threat
of investigations against Cohen to make
it so that he doesn't testify would be
witness tampering even if the threats
are about a possible investigation into
Cohen's father-in-law that would be
witness tampering and obstruction of
justice so I think no matter what the
supposed threats are I think no matter
what Michael Cohen is afraid of in terms
of physical safety his family is going
to be okay
the government can protect them and in
terms of investigatory risk that would
be witness tampering and obstruction of
justice by the president if what he is
saying is implicitly or explicitly if
you testify we will investigate your
father-in-law for whatever they believe
he may have done wrong Lanny Davis who
interestingly is Michael Cohen's
attorney now and is a big Clinton a
longtime Clinton friend says due to
ongoing threats against his family from
President Trump and mr. Giuliani as
recently as this weekend as well as mr.
Cohen's continued cooperation with
ongoing investigations by advice of
counsel mr. Cohen's appearance will be
postponed to a later date
Cohen thanks chairman Cummings for
allowing him to appear adding this is a
time when mr. Cohen had to put his
family and their safety first so big
picture I hope that he testifies I hope
that we ultimately do hear from Michael
Cohen because once again this is a
criminal enterprise that includes Donald
Trump's personal life Donald Trump's
business life and Donald Trump's
campaign life and if anyone is privy to
the criminality within all of the under
all of those umbrellas it would indeed
be Michael Cohen and possibly others as
well thanks to rel drah for becoming a
new member on YouTube you can use that
blue join button below our video not
every
has that YouTube including the David
Pakman show in a very very exciting beta
test of YouTube membership and rel drah
is the newest member along those lines
let's count that as one towards our goal
of 10 new members to open up the phone
lines and hear from people today three
ways that you can count towards that
goal of 10 become a member on our
website at david pakman.com slash
membership become a patron at
patreon.com slash david pakman show or
become a youtube member by pressing the
join button
sorry punch my mic there right below
this video all of those count and I will
open up the phone lines if we get to 10
um ok let me briefly mention this I'm
gonna talk about this tomorrow but I'll
mention it just briefly we've been
trying to figure out why is Rudy Rudy
Giuliani's behavior on television so
erratic saying that there was no
collusion than denying having denied
that there was collusion saying that
there is no way that Donald Trump would
have told Michael Cohen to lie in his
testimony to Congress but then saying
they may well have spoken but somehow he
knows even though he doesn't know what
was said he knows that what was not said
is that Trump definitely didn't tell Co
until I showing up on television and
having argued time and again that Trump
knew nothing and there were no payoffs
to mistresses and then saying yeah there
were payoffs and they were completely
legal what difference does it make all
of this very strange behavior from Rudy
Giuliani we've been trying to figure out
is the guy just a bad lawyer is he
experiencing some kind of cognitive
issue is this some kind of very slick
strategy to throw out every side of a
story with the idea of confusing
trumpets and making it sort of
impossible to know what is the truth
because in the end these aren't legal
statements from Rudy Giuliani he is a
lawyer sort of a name only he is really
a PR misinformation guy for Donald Trump
aids Republican aides are saying that
there's a much simpler explanation and
it's that Rudy Giuliani is
drinking alcohol before his appearances
on television sometimes the simplest
explanation is is the correct one a sort
of an an Occam's razor of stupidity
Trump's razor I guess is what we could
call it multiple aides expressing that
there is concern at the White House
about particularly the evening
appearances that Rudy Giuliani is doing
I haven't actually looked and kind of
divided the appearances into evening and
daytime maybe there's something to it
and when Rudy Giuliani was asked about
his drinking last May he said something
along the lines of I don't have a
drinking problem but sometimes I enjoy a
drink with dinner I like to drink I
think he said when I smoke cigars and he
says that drinking is not a factor here
but that is what three different
Republicans that spoke to The Associated
Press are saying they're saying it's
just a drinking issue that's it and that
explains everything that's going on with
Rudy Giuliani if that's the case it's
both sort of sad but it also does
explain a lot it explains a lot about
what we've been seeing so we'll dig into
that story in more detail tomorrow and
now I want to dig into the State of the
Union situation okay so let me let me
set this up for you and then we'll get
to the New York Times article the State
of the Union takes place yearly by
tradition and also by tradition it takes
place in the House of Representatives
during a joint session meaning that it's
in the House of Representatives which
has room for all 435 members of the
House and the hundred senators and the
Joint Chiefs and the Supreme Court
justices and some guests because it's
much bigger than the Senate okay
constitutionally all the president has
to do is from time to time issue a
statement about the State of the Union
the state of our nation it says nothing
about when it has to be it says nothing
about how frequently and it certainly
says nothing about the president having
any kind of right to show up uninvited
at the House of Representatives
the reason this invited versus uninvited
thing is relevant is that normally it's
a formality but this
Iger of the house invites the president
to come and brief both houses of
congress on what's going on and when I
say a formality I mean not that it
doesn't matter the president must be
invited but if government's open and
things are sort of normal no matter what
the party is of the person who's in the
White House and the Speaker of the House
whether it's the same party or different
parties they issue this invitation the
difference right now is that we have a
government shutdown and Nancy Pelosi
sent the letter to Donald Trump let me
see if I can pull up the article here
sent the letter that I accidentally
pulled up super shots sent a letter to
Donald Trump saying given the government
shutdown maybe we should reschedule
Donald Trump responded saying no
everything's fine
there's no security concerns I'm going
to give the speech in the House of
Representatives next Tuesday January
29th as originally planned and Nancy
Pelosi is just not having it and she has
now responded as is being reported by
the New York Times and numerous other
media outlets
she has responded that Donald Trump's
just not going to do it while we have a
government shutdown let me see if I can
find the exact quote
so as the New York Times article says
today Trump initially sent a letter
where he said he checked there's no
security concerns and he's going to be
able to do it Nancy Pelosi fired back a
letter saying no she's not going to pass
a resolution authorizing him to show up
there until the government is reopened
adding again I look forward to welcoming
you to the House on a mutually agreeable
date for this address when government
has been reopened
I believe Nancy Pelosi is going to win
this one and I support her in what she
is doing here
Nancy Pelosi is right that it is
ultimately up to her to decide whether
indeed the president is to be invited
and is to give a speech before the joint
session of the House and Senate or
whether he is not going to do that and I
don't know if Donald Trump has it in his
mind that Secret Service can just
overwhelm the sergeant-at-arms
and capital a House of Representatives
security congressional security and
force his way in there I don't know if
Trump imagines that if that were to be
the case that there would even be sort
of cameras and a crowd set up or how he
imagines that it would work but
ultimately this is Nancy Pelosi's call
and I think it is absolutely I mean
listen we know the state of the union
government has been shut down for a
record amount of time
Trump is throwing a temper tantrum like
a petulant child and holding all of
government hostage over his border wall
funding including 800,000 government
employees millions of associated
contractors people waiting for different
social welfare benefits that's the State
of the Union and meanwhile our allies
are laughing at us and ignoring the
United States when it comes to figuring
out what to do in terms of the climate
change circumstances in which we find
ourselves and all sorts of other issues
that's the State of the Union and I
agree
don't let trump come in and use the
State of the Union address and use Nancy
Pelosi's invitation to effectively hold
a build the wall rally because that's
what it would turn into okay if Donald
Trump does show up during a government
shutdown which is taking place because
the money for the wall that Trump wants
is not just being handed over to him
that's what it's going to be it's going
to be a build the wall rally and it'll
be a disgusting joke and I certainly
have no interest in seeing that happen
if it does happen I will cover it live
and we will do a live stream during the
State of the Union or whatever else the
most likely scenario if government
remains closed seems to be that Donald
Trump would do the speech but from a
different venue maybe from the Oval
Office I don't know I can't see him
submitting a report in writing
number one he doesn't really write and
number two you know this guy is all
about cameras and publicity and he is
going to be extraordinarily triggered if
Nancy Pelosi doesn't allow him to do
this and I think he would see sending a
written state of the Union address to
the House and Senate as losing and Trump
doesn't want to lose and that's why I
think ultimately he is going to find
some way to give a speech although where
it will happen in exactly when
I don't really know let's see anything
else from the New York Times article
here Trump's announcement he would come
to the Capitol despite concerns seemed
meant to put the Democratic leadership
on the spot Republican leaders piled on
retweet if you agree that the State of
the Union should proceed as plan let's
take a listen to this and see what this
is all about now more than ever our
country should see our government
leaders in the same room working to make
our future brighter this resolution I'm
about to sign would allow the State of
the Union to go on as planned okay yeah
so total and complete loser and total
publicity stunts before MS policies
response Democrat issued contradictory
language on the invitation Steny Hoyer
appeared Tuesday on Fox News asked if he
would be willing to host the president
he said sure that led to speculation
that he disagreed with MS Pelosi but on
Wednesday
Hoyer spoke to reporters and said the US
Capitol Police would be fully prepared
to provide security if Trump does
deliver the address Nancy and I are on
the same page she didn't disinvite him
what she said was she thought it would
be appropriate to choose a different
date he has not done so but then it
appears as though Nancy Pelosi is saying
no it's simply not going to happen so
I'm curious what people think about this
let me take a look at the chat and then
I'll get to some Super chats keep
calling it how it is Trump on the hook
for witness tampering what do people
think about the State of the Union
Donald will give us the state of the
Russian union Trumper czar so triggered
today do it at mar-a-lago that's an idea
I heard Trump recently seen under the
dome now he wants a dome there's
probably some double entendre there that
I'm not familiar with speech at Senate
chambers same cameras same same that's
interesting yeah Republicans do control
the Senate still so conceivably I guess
it would be sort of unusual but they
could invite Donald Trump to give the
speech in the Senate that's definitely a
possibility okay let me get to some of
the super chats here and before I do
that I do want to so we have or look
if we get 10 new members I'll open up
the phone lines at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 if
people want me to take phone calls
usually people do and we get a couple
dozen people to call in we do pay for
that multi phone line service so I've
set a target of 10 new supporters during
the stream Rell drah has become a
YouTube member I have one other new
member Robert lapel Robert lapel has
become a member at david pakman.com
slash membership so that's two and we're
looking for 10 I will remind you that
there are two coupon codes currently
available we're mostly funded by
membership on our website ok so if you
can afford to make a contribution to the
program I'm asking you to do that and
2019 is sort of a setup year for us to
be ready for 2020 as it just massive
massive may be the biggest year ever for
the show and so my priority for 2019 is
to grow membership as much as possible
and I'm willing to discount membership
in order to do that so there's a coupon
code which is this is 2020 and on the
second page of the signup process if you
type in this is to 0 to 0 you will save
40% off of the membership of your choice
so whether it's a $6 a month membership
or a hundred and $20 a year membership
any membership you like you can save 40%
with the coupon code this is 2020 and if
we get 10 supporters I will open up the
phone lines today and you can call in
and talk to me ok now we also have one
particular membership special and that
applies only to the $60 a year
membership so you switch the tab to
yearly and hit the signup button and
then the coupon code you enter is 2019
ok two zero one nine if you do that you
will get a yearly membership for $20.19
okay that's like $1 something a month
ninety-five percent of our audience can
afford a dollar something a month if you
can't don't do it I'm still doing the
show for you all of our content exists
for everybody but if you can afford a
dollar something a month do the right
thing it'll feel good I know you will
feel good about it I will also thank you
on the stream and we will get to open a
the phone lines the coupon code is two
zero one nine $20.19 and you can keep
that rate for as long as you want
keep it ten years if you want no problem
whatsoever
Joshua Carr who is a what we call a
david pakman show triple threat Joshua
Carr is a YouTube contributor a david
pakman show member and a david pakman
show patron and he is in there with the
super chat Joshua car with the ten
British Pound super chat says due to
confirmation bias do you expect lack of
impeachment as something that would
galvanize Trump space for 2020 as we
know all of his shenanigans don't seem
to affect his base whatsoever yes so
you're right Joshua in that if Trump is
not impeached and that's the most likely
scenario and by impeached
I mean removed I know that impeached
doesn't actually mean removed impeached
means the house starts impeachment the
Senate then has to decide whether to
remove Donald Trump or not but
colloquially people often say
impeachment is the removal the most
likely scenario is that Donald Trump is
not going to be removed from office
before 2020 he's gonna have to be voted
out
trumpets we'll see that as a reason to
support Trump they'll say the biggest
most biased investigation witch-hunt
against Trump media the FBI everybody
against Trump and still they couldn't
get him my support for him is redoubled
the thing is it's not going to matter
because they're voting for him anyway I
mean the cognitive dissonance that the
average Trump is tech's periences is
such that whether Trump is or isn't
impeached they are voting for Trump and
this is why I've been pleading imploring
people since basically the day Trump was
inaugurated we are not going to win in
2020 by arguing with crumpets and
changing their minds it's just not the
way we're going to win in 2020 half the
country doesn't vote we are going to win
by getting people to vote okay the new
activists that were activated and
galvanized by the Trump presidency if
they all get out and vote in 2020
Trump's done are they going to do that I
don't know
young people have a long track record of
not doing a lot of voting relative to
other groups any time that someone has
not voted before that is an indicator
that they may not vote next time now of
course if you weren't old enough to vote
in 2016 and you will be in 2020 that's
different but when you create a likely
voter model unlike with investments past
performance is indicative of future
results people that regularly have voted
in the past are more likely to vote in
the future and young people are often
not on the correct side of that so my
advice is don't waste your time arguing
with Trumpets if you're having some fun
on Facebook or Twitter if you enjoy the
art of it have at it but as an electoral
strategy
it's about get out the vote when half
the country doesn't vote and you know
Trump is calling to my show all the time
you can probably realize from that that
they are not easily going to have their
minds change particularly because they
this kind of you bought it you own it
mentality they want to save face and
they are likely to vote for Trump's
reelection in 2020 so it's got to be a
voter turnout thing 100 percent no
question about it let me say thanks to
Mark Moyer who is the third new member
during today's live stream we had rel
drah and we had the other new member
that I mentioned and now we also have
mark Moyer and annalisa Chavira annalisa
Chavira has signed up taking advantage
of that just massive massive membership
special really really appreciate that
the membership special with the coupon
code to zero one nine drops a $60
membership to $20.19 we do about a
hundred videos a month and with the
coupon code 2019 you're basically
talking about a penny and a half per
video okay a video where we are doing
research on screen production editing
distribution to 200 radio and television
stations and YouTube and the podcast a
penny and a half okay with the 29
teen discount code and almost everyone
in our audience can afford that so thank
you to annalisa Chavira and also thanks
to Gabriel Harris who has just signed up
at david pakman.com slash membership
Gabriel Harris is number four that makes
four of ten new members during the live
stream 40% of the way there when we get
to 10 I'll open the phones and take call
after call for for a while it is my turn
to make dinner tonight so I can't be
here all night but if we get six more
members I will open up the phone lines
and actually it's five more because
Holly Aguilar has just signed up using
the coupon code 2019 at david pakman.com
slash membership Holly thank you very
much appreciate that five more and I
will open up the phone lines horror view
with two R's sends a five-dollar super
chat what is the purpose of listing job
government qualifications if people like
Trump's children and Friends can be
hired with no qualified skills
I'm guessing mean what's the purpose of
listing government job qualifications
yeah I mean it's a it's a completely
fair question we have nepotism nepotism
incarnate is I guess what we would call
the current administration a we would
still like to sort of believe that
credentials matter and experience
matters but when you've got Ivanka Trump
filling in for former Secretary of State
Rex Tillerson and was it Korea maybe and
all of the other stuff it's it's
extraordinarily depressing Kody Stegman
has signed up for YouTube membership
please number six number six of ten
today we are 60% of the way to me
opening up the phone lines and hearing
from folks sixes six s's not sure how to
pronounce that sends a $6 and 66 cents
super chat stop wearing suits sweaters
are a better look for you that's
something to think about I think the
suit is just it's much more it's more
professional and you know people already
write in all the time saying David
you look 17 and you seem like a little
kid and you're not credible and all that
stuff I think wearing a suit jacket
helps a little bit although at this
point being almost in my mid-30s I
should probably just be okay I just got
a message that we had a bit of a of an
interruption there in the stream did
anybody else see the stream interrupted
hmm show has been hacked some people are
saying that OBS which is what I use for
the live streams sent me a message
saying that the stream was interrupted
but is now back crashed back red alert
yes yes yes
FFF interrupted back ok I think I think
we're back I think we're back back on
board good ok couple other new members
to mention Curt Hobbs is 7 of 10 Jessica
McCabe is 8 of 10 and Steve Denning is 9
of 10 we're almost there we may get more
phone calls today and more audience
participation than we've had in a long
time people loving the coupon code 2019
which drops a $60 membership to just
$20.19 we're 90% of the way there okay
so if you want the phone lines opened up
just one more person using that coupon
code or not really it's up to you how
you sign up patreon YouTube membership
website membership we are getting
dangerously close dangerously close to
opening up the phone lines and I really
appreciate that
okay few other things to mention
actually let me see let me just check in
on what's going on in the regular chat
because people seem to be saying a lot
of a lot of stuff they're people saying
the stream is down again I'm not seeing
the stream is down the stream seems to
be completely fine live stream stopped
did you know it all seems to be fine on
my end back it's gone switch your ISP we
have fiber with a 900 megabit upload and
it it works really well honestly we've
had we've had
very very few problems so I don't think
I don't think we're in trouble I think
that we're gonna do just fine okay
Isabella M is the latest YouTube member
and Cathy Sachs Tedder has signed up on
our website so that is uh that's 11
built by all means don't stop signing up
but I will as promised you know if
anything I tell you the truth when I
tell you I'm going to open up the phone
lines I open up the phone lines let me
get that set up here and we will take
some phone calls from the audience and
see what's going on the phone number is
six one seven eight three zero 47:56
one seven eight three zero 4750 is the
number and we will soon be hearing from
folks if they want to call in will I
accept calls from regular callers
tonight I don't know I don't know about
that I like to get given you people a
chance we'll see it depends how many
people are interested in having their
voices heard today six one seven eight
three zero
4750 I will momentarily go to live calls
let me just get all set up for it here
I've got to get all my screens properly
set up in the meantime a couple of other
super chats here
Leoben says what did you think of Bari
Weiss on Rogen didn't see it didn't see
it
Gabe from Utah two blue dollars viva
Argentina yes thank you two dollars in
Argentina now is something like I think
76 Argentinean pesos they're having all
sorts of currency problems down there
okay let me go to the phones
I'll keep super chats up and answer
questions there as they come in let's go
first to our caller from Skype caller
from Skype company
hey David this is Miles from Arizona
um I've I have a question about the
molar disputing the the whole BuzzFeed
article yep why do you think they
disputed that article like because I
out of box and actually even Fox News
said that crazy Rudy Guiliani said that
they talked to molars team which to me
thinks did Rudy Guiliani or maybe even
Matthew Whitaker was he pressured into
discrediting the BuzzFeed article like
why do you think the BuzzFeed article
was discredited I don't know to be very
very clear the BuzzFeed article was not
discredited in any general sense right
statement problem let me be more
specific
yeah no I understand I'll just clarify
miles and then we'll continue with the
analysis molar spokesperson put out a
statement saying that some specific
testimony that the art that the article
asserted was made to the special
counsels office was not accurately
described and some of the
characterizations were not accurate that
could simply mean that it's not
testimony that was made to the special
counsel's office and it was made to the
Southern District of New York for
example which would merely discredit the
venue but it would not go against the
underlying assertions so you know to say
that the article was discredited
for me when both Rudy Giuliani and a
White House spokesperson both refused to
completely deny that the story is
accurate that to me is the biggest
indicator that it probably is at least
in spirit the the accurate
representation of what happened yeah cuz
again I know like Russia's denier I
support Muller I but I want to believe
that the article was true yeah but just
when molar comes out and says it's not
accurate then I'm suddenly scratching my
head and kind of wondering well did was
this a situation where they might have
messed up a little on yeah it seems as
though you know when the the article had
a ton of stuff in it and the the
statement from the from molars office
was very very narrow so I think it's
important when lawyers put out such
narrowly worded statements only read
into it what they're actually saying all
right miles I got a run I've got a ton
of people holding here great to hear
from you again now let's go to the 703
area code hey David yeah yeah
so I I was looking at some polls about
Trump's approval rating and one of them
by NPR and PBS newshour showed that in
the last week that Trump's approval
rating with Latinos went up by 19
percent to 50 percent is job approval
which poll kind of it's a NPR PBS
Newshour Marist Poll NPR yeah EBS Marist
Trump let me look at that
yeah I it was kind of strange because I
mean he literally just talked the whole
week about the border wall so I was
wondering what made his I guess his
approval jump that much with Hispanics
in the last week okay so let's see I'm
taking I'm trying to pull it up right
now
you know oh you know I've seen this pole
this pole is mostly terrible news for
Trump and it's interesting that the only
thing in it that could even be argued to
be good for Trump is this increased
approval with the Latino population and
there's a whole bunch of reasons why
polling the American Latino population
is very very difficult and we don't know
need to go into the full merits of that
right now but that poll is mostly bad
news for Trump and the one thing that
he's claiming is positive is dubious at
best so I mean listen if he believes the
poll then most of it is bad news for him
so it's it's I mean if that's a poll
that he trusts I would be concerned
because it's it's mostly bad news okay
yeah cuz he tweeted about it and then I
thought it was a fake focus he usually
just cites some random stats but it was
looked at it was actually real so the
poll is real and I think we've got to
kind of understand some of the
difficulties of polling Latinos and the
fact that it that the poll is the poll
basically is bad news for him all right
thank you David okay thanks very much
let me get to a couple of other calls
momentarily but first
we thank Joseph Taverna who has signed
up at david pakman.com slash membership
supporting the show with a membership
thank you please keep signing up stephen
brent is a new youtube member Thank You
Steven Alexander read with a fifty
Norwegian kroner super chat can the
shutdown end or stop the Moller Russia
investigation I see the headline courts
will run out of money by Friday
including molars grand jury I've read
that this idea before but from the legal
opinions I've looked at so far no the
shutdown is not going to stop the molar
investigation
mavis Leyva's MAV is Lavis with a $2
super chat what's for dinner tonight I'm
making salmon tonight or Salman as I
like to call it should be quite a dish
phrenic 32 says bring back the David
Pakman cooking show yeah there's a video
of me making Spanish tortilla up on
YouTube which you can check out may be
something I would consider bringing back
we'll see Joey tech talks says hi David
I didn't end up homeless and the reason
I was about to be last time I did this
wasn't due to finances but other reasons
okay Joey with peace and love I don't
remember the reference we get a lot of
super chats and calls and stuff but
obviously I'm glad you're not ending up
homeless I would not want that let's go
to the eight one four area code caller
from eight one four what's going on
hello David thank you
this is John from Edinboro Pennsylvania
just south of Erie PA very nice uh I
have a prediction I'm feeling kind of
nostradamus desk right now okay and and
then a question for you my prediction is
that since he will not be able to
deliver his State of Union speech in
Congress that Trump's team right now is
working on somewhere he can go to one of
his campaign type stops and deliver his
speech in front of a you know crowd of
acolytes and my question is now
obviously
not going to deliver the speech in
Congress Nancy Pelosi is not going to
change your mind short of the government
being open before Tuesday if he does
deliver it in a you know a campaign type
studying one of those rallies or from
the White House will all the networks
cover it or guess they are they obligate
think they're obligated to but they will
cover it that's for sure so I think it
would be you know I I don't think it's
that outlandish just think Trump will
literally turn the State of the Union
into a rally as you're suggesting but I
think if he gives a speech which is at
least nominally titled the State of the
Union even if it's not at the House of
Representatives I think networks will
absolutely cover it and I would I would
as well by the way because I'd want to
hear what he says well yeah I mean and
as much as I hate listening to him but I
would watch myself II now with that
question hey go ahead the last caller
what what do you make of the fact that
here and of course many many of Latino
Americans are people that you know that
didn't come here that they were born
here and and you know second third
generation here but what do you make of
the fact that he is realizing an
increase in support from Latinos you
know when it's couched around this issue
of a border wall and everything I just I
just I'm perplexed by that I am not yet
convinced that he really is seeing a
surge of support from Latinos Latinos
are overwhelmingly liberal and other
than Cubans and it's it's notoriously
difficult to poll Latinos for a number
of reasons so let's wait until we get
more polling about Latino support for
Trump before we start figuring out why
they're supporting him in higher numbers
let's first establish that they are
alright appreciate it thank you very
much great to hear from you
okay let me get to a couple of other
super chats and then we'll stick with
the phone's Jay Lynch says your
it's on the IRA viewer from Ireland J
you know that is one of the the
geopolitical issues I know the least
about and I just don't feel qualified to
really say much about the IRA unless
you're talking about IRA retirement
accounts in which case I could I could
say a lot horror fan for life says huge
fan debate fake news Hannity please I
don't think Hannity is interested in
debating me also with a follow-up PS are
you a horror film fan or a fan or a fan
of the genre of the genre III don't
really watch horror films now it's not
yeah I I could probably count on two
fingers the number of actual horror
films that I've watched let's go to a
caller from what I think is country code
49 country code 49 does that ring a bell
no yeah yeah who's this you know yes I
might hello I am calling from Germany oh
hey my a very very big fantasy show
thank you thank you and and I was
wondering if you could make a segment or
if you could talk about what you thought
about the decline of the Social
Democratic parties in Europe especially
the European Union for example the
Pacific air hockey application if that
if you know what I'm talking about yeah
I've actually been following the decline
of some of the Social Democratic parties
not in Europe in general but in some
specific countries and it's an
interesting phenomenon and I wonder I
mean you might know more about this than
I do
are is there actually a decline in the
ideology that they represent or is it
merely that the parties themselves are
what's falling out of favor but the
ideas other than of course this kind of
nationalist slide that we've seen is it
that the ideas are becoming more
integrated into more mainstream leftism
in Europe and the Social Democratic
parties aren't the only place where you
can get those positions is that a
possibility I do think it's a
combination of both actually if you
think of Great Britain with New Labour
and we had something
Germany as well and with the when
Gerhard schröder was Chancellor yeah was
in the Social Democratic Party of
Germany and I think that was a reason
why many people of confidence and both
the Social Democratic parties attached
and but also there the ideology of
social democracy in the West business as
when political ideals and I might not to
Democrat myself and I'm very concerned
about this this decline which is also I
think it is connected with the rise of
the right wing and right populist party
if the only thing about that you know is
that makes me think about that is if you
are a social democrat you're not very
likely to go to like a right-wing
nationalist party you might become more
centrist but it's it's such a wild swing
that I hesitate to say that that's one
of the reasons although I mean the
nationalism has gone up and the social
democracy has gone down so the numbers
are sort of there well I don't think I
think it's more of a gradual process and
not approve the changing for example we
have other than these sources and I
think some some form of Social Democrats
or which were center-left also become
more or less and others become a
centrist or even right-wing so I think
we the Social Democrats losing traction
also in other countries where first an
example in Italy I'm also happy time as
well and Italy the Social Democrats have
lost many of the roads to the five star
movement which populace in nature they
are just they are so incredibly populist
with this override any of what could be
seen as an ideology of right-wing or
left-wing also so for example they say
they're anti-immigration
because that's what many people like to
hear what they also say therefore invite
and environmentalism
which is more of a left-wing thing and
they're against internationalism in in a
way that they do not support the
European Union but they want to the
support of the European Union because
they get money from the European Union
and it doesn't make any sense at all but
it it speaks to the people and that's
why they are very popular and I okay
well let me look into it more and then
follow up I appreciate the call
marchello very very great to hear from
people in Germany appreciate it
before I get back to the phones a couple
of other super chats here to address
Matthew Long says why do you never talk
about your personal life I thought that
I did I mean maybe it's more on the
bonus show which all members and patrons
would have access to so keep signing up
but I thought I did what do you want to
know maybe maybe send a super chat with
a question Lou guy says does Trump
reflect American culture value system
well America is at least two distinct
culture and value systems cultures and
value systems and according to some
demographers and sociologists there are
anywhere from nine to eleven sort of
distinct cultures in the United States
regionally so I think the answer is
certainly not all of it but you know
there are people whose ideology is
basically whatever will get a an
ostensible right-wing or elected and
Trump did what he had to do and they
voted for him so he certainly represents
that faction of American society let's
go to the 7 to 0 area code we are taking
calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 you're
looking for the number it is 6 1 7 8 3 0
47 50 caller from 70 to 0 what's going
on 7 to 0 if you you've muted yourself
while you were waiting maybe unmute
because we can't hear you
yeah hey I was talking about how
we can get you know progressives to come
out and vote and vote Trump out yeah I
was wondering do you what's your
position on compulsory voting or
mandatory voting you know I'm very mixed
on it because my home country of
Argentina has it and has I think it's
like a 96 or 98 percent voter turnout
and there are a lot of positive effects
of having a huge portion of the
population participate but the question
is do you get all of those effects if
voting is mandatory rather than people
voting because they want to so I've
actually not taken a position on
compulsory voting I don't have any
problem with it legally I don't have any
problem with it morally or ethically I
think it's something that some countries
say is that that's how they're that's
how they're doing it but I'm not sure
actually whether if you said David you
can now pick is voting mandatory in the
US or does it remain optional which do
you do i I'm not sure okay thank you all
right no problem yeah I should really I
should take a position on that shouldn't
I
sinister Minister sends a $2 super chat
fool in the rain one of my favorite Led
Zeppelin songs David I love that you're
doing more live chats this year keep it
up I will for as long as people want
them Dave do you think it says do you
think a o'seas twitch stream appearance
is in any way a game-changer in terms of
political public outreach yeah I heard
she appeared on a stream that was
raising money for I think it was trans
rights um is it a game-changer you know
when she did her mac and cheese on
Instagram thing a couple months later
Elizabeth Warren had a beer on Instagram
live so maybe I mean maybe it will be a
game-changer who am I to say it won't be
let's go to the 7/7 three area code call
her from seven seven three go ahead
hey David can you hear me yeah we can
hear you fine cool my name is Luke I'm
calling from Chicago I've been listening
because for a couple years first time
call to me cool
and I was just calling because earlier
today
when Nancy Pelosi pretty much you know
just disinvited the president for the
State of the Union after she did that I
watched his sort of response on TV and
then he answered questions from
reporters but his response was one life
from beginning to end just lie lie lie
lie lie yes angry and I think something
that people don't really think about is
that there's a very real psychological
aspect to this guy he's a malignant
narcissist he dies and gas light and
it's it's it's textbook so you have to
almost separate his behavior from his
position and policies when he's tweeting
like that and lying like that he's sick
sick broadcasting his pathology it's not
real it's just anger it almost didn't
have words he was just shouting or
growling or something it would be really
the same in essence but you think about
it yeah I completely agree with you it's
just not really having a downside for
him in the sense that his supporters
love it or at least they're not
dissuaded by it and you know if you try
to explain to them that Donald Trump's
behavior is that of a significantly
mentally disturbed person who needs help
they're not going to hear it you know so
I think that he's doing what he feels
like doing he's not really suffering
from it from in terms of his base so why
not continue you know exactly and I have
one other question what do you think
about the Michael Cohen backing out of
his testimony I mean how is what Trump
and Giuliani have done not on its face
maybe witness tampering but certainly
obstructing justice yeah if it's true it
is both of those things and we opened up
the stream with that so I won't i won't
redo my commentary now but you can
either behind that find our live and and
check it out yeah thank you so much
really appreciate it great to hear from
you horror fan for life sends a super
chat asking how do we explain to
right-wingers that the old Democrats
were basically the conservatives of
today they just switched drives me nuts
PS lock him up yeah there was a party
alignment but it's actually more
complicated than that and I saw that
right-wing guy who I think his coke
funded Charlie Charlie cork I think his
name is I'm kidding
and he he was talking about you know
something that clearly ignored the party
realignment and I don't know if they
play dumb with that or if they genuinely
don't get it
Daniel Appel says what we know you're
supportive of the gay community do you
have any gay friends or family um I have
many gay friends and I have see I've got
a cousin I have a cousin who's gay and
maybe maybe someone else I don't
remember I don't really categorize
people in that way because I'm so
progressive and enlightened you know
Daniel but yeah I mean it's there's at
least a couple of people who are part of
the LGBT community in my family in
Argentina actually Mike Schafer says $15
minimum wage House bill for the wall
good compromise sure but I mean just you
know it's not gonna happen it's not uh
it's not even one that's it's a
non-starter to put it lightly let's go
to the three one nine area code call her
from three one nine you're on the air
hello hello I'm Russell
I'm Cedar Rapids area great um I just
curious and wanted to ask what's your
opinion on Tim Poole I'm sorry on who
Tim Poole he's uh oh yeah I met him
before actually he was at UH he was at
what was the name of that thing I did in
LA he was at politican and he was
actually at one of the events I did he
was in the audience I don't really watch
anything he does so I I saw he did a
video with this guy named Carl Benjamin
who goes by sargon of akkad on the
Internet
and in that video Sargon claimed that I
said something like Stalin is right Oh a
right-winger and Tim Poole laughed or
something like that but otherwise I
don't really see any of his stuff I'm
friends with him on Facebook and he
sends me message
on Facebook sometimes but I don't really
know what he's up to I personally think
the two of you have a good enough
contrast where some interesting debates
could come up if you decided to get on
friendly terms
oh I were not on unfriendly terms I just
don't I don't really watch anything so I
don't know what he's putting out there
you know he's a bit more to the right of
you yes I'm aware of that that piece I'm
aware of from his uh from the
conversations I've had with him okay
thanks very much appreciate the call
good to hear from you thanks to Tom
interval for the five-dollar super chat
let's go to the three one three area
code caller from three one three and
before you you jump in three one three
let me thank Jamie Sprague who has
signed up at david pakman.com slash
membership really appreciate that okay
three one three you're on the air oh hi
David can you hear me
yeah I can hear you fine okay uh my name
is Tony I'm calling from Michigan okay
sorry
I have a question uh but first I have to
preface it practice it with another
question about your political
affiliation okay are you a social
democrat or in any way agreeing with
that faction yeah I mean I consider I'm
not as I'm not a Democratic Socialist so
yeah I consider myself an advocate of
social democracy okay
so uh I like to agree with you on that
sort of front but as a lover of politics
I like to get my classmates and friends
engaged politically however when I say
I'm social democrat most of my peers
automatically assume that I am the
negative connotation of a socialist how
do I convince these people that my
values are rational and somewhat popular
so there's a couple different approaches
it depends who you're talking to I mean
big picture there is a lot of confusion
between social democracy and democratic
socialism particularly when you see
elected officials calling themselves
Democratic socialists but then only
advocating for social democracy in terms
of the policies so if we could get that
sorted out that would be kind of like
the best thing but you can
the term social democrat altogether
because remember a social democrat wants
a mixed economy
it's a capitalist economy but it's a
well-regulated one where there is
significant social welfare apparatus
there to create you know we're basically
saying we're going to have inequality
and we're going to have sort of a
sorting that takes place based on
people's skills and effort and and
desires and all of this different stuff
but you shouldn't be punished for that
we're gonna kind of set the floor so
that you're not going to be punished for
not being super successful in business
or being able to get an advanced
education and therefore a good job so I
think that one approach is you don't
even have to say you're a social
democrat you can say you are for well
regulated capitalism and then you just
give examples and maybe that would avoid
some of those negative connotations
right I have another question if there's
time but if you're out that's fine yeah
what's up up okay so I like to talk to
my peers about politics and that kind of
stuff however when I get into a deep
conversation with them I find that a lot
of them are turned off and I don't
really care about politics as much as I
do
hmm is there any sort of advice or tips
you could give to someone like me who
wants to get their peers more engaged
politically well how do you even get
into a deep conversation if they don't
care well I sort of just try to assess
what kind of political party they they
agree with or what values they have yeah
and most of the time they don't really
know what they're talking about or they
don't really understand where I'm coming
from
sure I just want to sort of enlighten
them on how the political realm works I
mean I think that the best way so this
is kind of like for people who just say
I'm not really into politics ask them
what they do care about this came up
during live walls recently ask them what
they do care about and they'll often say
something that is actually very much
related to politics they might just not
understand how and then explain to them
how that's related to politics even if
they don't see it and why it matters all
right okay good thank you for the call
appreciate it great questions
Hayden Barrow let asks via super chat
have you
watch destiny the politicals twitch
streamer not only have I watched him
he's been on my channel at least twice
and we might do something maybe sometime
in the future yeah I like him a lot
Carlos Gonzales with the $2 super chat
izanagi with a $2 super chat thing you
thank you for your hard work it means a
lot Dave with a $5 super chat what
obstacles does a OC face that has you
the most worried about a potential
decrease of her political influence what
should we be looking out for she just
needs to get as informed as possible as
quickly as possible because the
spotlight is on her Fox News is obsessed
with her she's getting attention she's
doing a lot of great things she needs to
be weather fairly or unfairly what she
says is going to be scrutinized for
accuracy and so she needs to get as
informed as possible about the issues
she's discussing Azura's says David can
you tell me you love me love you hope
that was hope that was good for you
glorious then dartie is a new david
pakman show member thank you very much
and I will go to the 502 area code for
our next live call it was going on David
hey so I told you I called yesterday
about you know the Scott from Kentucky I
forgot to ask this question yeah that I
probably should have before it's a
slightly non-political / kind of
political in a sense kind of wait do you
think it's time for the progressive left
to join cutie pie in the fight against
e-series I don't know what anything like
that is so I let's see let's see if we
can break it down pewdiepie I know is
just a big YouTube streamer who's had a
bunch of controversies where didn't he
have both the swastika and an n-word
incident recently well there's a you
know so that you know like Vox media in
the Wall Street Journal there they're
publishing articles about him because
one time recently he played this online
video game with you know with a cup with
a bunch of random you know streamers and
one of them happened to have user name
Slade that had hidden you know nazia
references and then you know that he was
unaware of until he knows people they
did some a bunch of digging and found it
and then he shouted out a channel
that I think it's a little more than
that but what's TC what does that mean
the t-series is Indian Indian they're a
music production company and so the
sorts are sort of populist movement
going on right now and all these guys
are subscribed if you do PI you know
putting up billboards and Scott spends a
million dollars on the billboard in
Times Square
you know mr. beast us but no billboards
and going on radio shows and who's know
these sorry who's mr. pasty mr. beast
nobody's uh particularly been like
right-wing you know in the in moderates
and video and gamers that have been
joined in it but I think it would be
incredibly ironic you know it's the left
and you know but you maybe not the far
left that like that leaves him is a is a
not seen such like out of context but
what's left you know the secular and
reasonable progresses you know joy edge
on the side and like listen I don't know
where's my stuff I couldn't tell you
whether you're even characterizing any
of it accurately so I couldn't tell you
anything about PewDiePie Ortiz or
anything like that let me put it down
this way YouTube is you know how it's
sort of been burnt nurtured by the
individual creators for like 15 years it
recently it's become a lot more
corporate you know it's the monetization
and censorship and they had talked
ellipse and all this and then and we
they've been pushing really corporate
stuff to the trending page and you know
silencing you know certain a bunch of
channels and you know PewDiePie sort of
led this movement that you know it's
like there's one guy you know there's
been making YouTube videos on his own in
gaming versus you know the tour for it
faceless machine you know this or taking
over and it's still nothing with me I
still just I couldn't tell you I don't
know anything about it I appreciate the
call like it's for other people that's
just out of my it's out of my area of
expertise okay Stu Neff stun ever says
love the show if we give this clown any
more money for the wall he will shut
down the government or worse again every
time he doesn't get his way
absolutely you can't let him see
government shutdowns as a way to get
stuff absolutely
Tom interval says hey David I'm one of
the new January members love your show
according to your Instagram account
you're a drummer what's the origin of
your interest are you good and do you
ever play publicly the origin of my
just as I just got into drumming when I
was like 19 I'm not very good I mean
listen I been playing for a long time
but I'm not I'm not Steve Gadd you know
and do I play publicly I've played in a
bunch of bands and we've had public gigs
I'm not in a band right now so right now
there's no place that you could see me
play publicly Kimmy says what's your
view of NATO and US defence of Europe I
support u.s. membership in NATO Mike
Schaeffer says oujet 'as charisma as
vice president make up for Warren's lack
of Irene or he'd Richard Oh Jetta he
didn't strike me as particularly
charismatic so I'm not sure about that
read nurs 11 says is the shutdown away
to delay or avoid the Michael Cohen
hearing think about it or maybe Cohen
never really intended to testify if
Cohen never intended to testify the
shutdown is irrelevant even with the
shutdown Cohen still could have
testified in two weeks so no I don't
think so
Azura x' says David after pooping do you
sit or stand to wipe extraordinary
question and very very weird okay let's
go to our caller from the 900 thank you
very much hey David how's it going this
is Daniel I'm calling from North
Carolina
go ahead Daniel I just wanted to preface
the question wanted to ask you with this
comments about a guest that you had on
your show recently a couple of weeks ago
you had tweeted they were gonna have
Scott Adams on your show right and I
asked what you wanted to have us ask him
and I replied with this question I'm
about to ask you and I'm not expecting
you to condone this attack on that
insecure coward Scott Adams but he
called me brainwashed for some reason
for asking a legitimate question was
about to ask so basically my question
was I'm assuming that the economy is
going to tank this year big time
okay and I was asking whether he thought
that if the economy Thanks if we have
shrinking GDP and rising unemployment
whether Trump can effectively convince
his
and supporters that it's all just a
bunch of fake news and bullcrap and I
was basically saying that I believe that
he'll be essentially just denying
straight-up facts like the Fed saying
that the GDP is growing when in fact
it's just factually not and that this
won't be much of an issue for him if he
still visits a campaign if he still
makes it to the 2020 campaign but I was
just wondering if if you thought that
Trump would be able to convince the
supporters in that same way if that
happened yeah probably I mean his
supporters don't care about the facts
and as long as he gives them something
they can repeat they're gonna vote for
him and this is why the 2020 election
cannot and will not come down to what
message gets to Trump's base it's going
to come down to other people getting out
and voting okay yeah I I just think that
America had is like a freaking it's like
a mind washing machine at this point
yeah it it really isn't thank you so
much for the call okay I appreciate it
that's gonna do it for today's stream I
got a run thanks to everybody who joined
me we'll have a new show tomorrow use
that coupon code to 0:19 it'll give you
a $60 membership for only $20 and 19
cents for the year that's a good deal
that's like a penny and a half for each
video that we